Heat. Heat.
[Silence]
Shalom.
Oh,
I shall.
I sh
Oh,
I
sat.
I got
I love you.
Allah
love
you.
Heat. Heat.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Now,
[Silence]
Yeah.
has.
[Silence]
format.
for
now.
Allah
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu waala
tells us in no uncertain terms
and
this meaning is iterated and reiterated
ated throughout the entirety of the
Quran
both verbatim and in spirit.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says what
translates to
and what could Allah possibly want
with your punishment.
If you are thankful and you believe
of what use to Allah
is it to punish you speaking to humanity
all of us speaking to you speaking to me
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala asks
rhetorically
and of what use
is your punishment to Allah
If you are thankful and believe
and indeed Allah is more thankful,
Allah is most thankful.
He is most gracious
and Allah is most worthy of your thanks.
And he verily
knows all that is, all that was, all
that is to be. Subhan.
Now this statement here crumbles much
of the whispers
propaganda
mis
construed
distorted impressions that a shan
whispers into the hearts of men.
This
shatters those myths
and that is that human beings naturally
receive whispers from a shan to think
the worst thoughts about Allah
and that truly those who are dumped into
the hellfire,
they are finding themselves there in the
hellfire because they fed in to the
whispers of a shaitan
and those whispers are related to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
listening and believing
the very distorted
very cynical
beliefs that a shan tries to drive home
into the hearts of men.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
the people of the hellfire
when they find themselves in the
hellfire it will be said to them
it is your beliefs
your your estimate of Allah that has
landed you here into hellfire
your unjust estimate of Allah
believing
in the most cynical way in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that when something
bad happens to you
a shaitan whispers for you to believe
that this is somehow Allah always
punishing you anything painful that
happens it's only punishment from Allah
and if you listen to the whispers of a
shan time. He will make you the most
cynical, most negative
person,
always feeding you distorted ideas and
beliefs in Allah.
As if Allah is sadistic. As if he wants
to see you in pain.
As if pain is the essential bedrock of
your existence and mercy is only
something that happens in small portions
occasionally, incidentally
that you must go to hell. There's no way
you can escape hell.
that you are not in any way close to
Allah. You have no chance of being close
to Allah. Therefore, don't waste your
life trying to not go to hell. You're
going to go anyways no matter what. So,
you know, try a little bit, but enjoy
your life here.
These are the ideas, the misconceptions
that Allah breathes into the chests of
men.
They start to believe the most cynical
things about Allah
to the point that we even have sayings,
we even have idioms in popular culture
that just ooze with this cynicism.
they say in America and the west
they say no good deed goes unpunished.
No good deed goes unpunished. Meaning
anytime you try to be good, you'll get
bit.
You'll get bit because no good deed goes
unpunished by God.
These kinds of ideas, these thoughts,
they build up over time. They they build
up plaque on a person's heart over
time until they think that they see
Allah and really all they are looking at
as a is a shan.
They are looking at the devil himself
confusing
these things and conflating them with
the descriptions of Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
he says in
[Silence]
listen to the descriptions that Allah
gives. He says, "And when Musam
went,
he went to that mountain for the meeting
of Allah for 40 days and 40 nights."
Benis and in his absence they took the
gold that they had and the jewelry that
they had and they forged
a golden heer a golden calf
that they then worshiped aside from
Allah
in the absence of Musam
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says do they
not see that this golden idol of theirs
neither speaks to them nor guides them.
Listen to the description. Do they not
see that this golden calf that they are
worshiping aside from Allah, it neither
speaks to them nor guides them.
Meaning Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
speaks to us and he guides us and this
idol neither speaks to them nor guides
them. How could they worship this and
leave off the worship of Allah?
Do you think that Allah does not speak
to you? That he does not speak to me.
You don't need to hear a voice in your
head that is Allah speaking to every
single one of us. He has left with us a
book that if any book could resurrect
the dead, it would be this book, the
Quran.
In it is the response for any question
you or I or all of humanity would ever
have or will ever have. You just have to
know how to read the book. You have to
know where to find the response of
Allah. You have a question. This book,
the Quran, is the most vivid mirror
on this planet.
You at every moment, at every step down
the path of Allah may open this book and
find your exact description in the
Quran.
And not only will it find you find your
exact description, he will describe to
you where you are, where you should be,
and how to get there.
But you have to learn how to read this
book. You have to learn how to find
those answers. You and I,
every other human being, who are we to
expect that Allah will speak to every
single one of us when we have every
little question? He has sent down a book
that has in it the guidance for all that
was and is to be.
He has already spoken to you and he
guides you. And when you speak to him,
he responds every time. Every single
time
in Muslim
Abu
narrates
that the prophet Sam
said that Allah himself has said
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Abdi.
[Silence]
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
Eugene.
[Silence]
Subhanah.
Listen to this narration in Muslim. Our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam says that
Allah himself has said he has proclaimed
I have divided prayer
between myself and my servant
into two equal halves and to my for my
servant whatever he asks.
He says, "So when the servant stands in
salah before Allah
and says in his salah, all praise,"
meaning fat, all praise is due to Allah,
Lord of the words. Allah responds
in real time. Allah responds and says,
"My slave has praised me."
And if he says the beneficent, the most
merciful, Allah responds,
my servant has doubled down on his
praise of me.
And when the servant says, "The king,
the sovereign king and owner and
possessor of the day of recompense,
Allah responds,
"My slave has proclaimed my greatness."
And when the slave says, "You alone do
we worship and you alone do we beseech
and aid," Allah responds
and says, "This is between my slave and
myself and for my slave whatever he asks
of me."
And when the servant, you, me, everyone
who stands before Allah making salah,
when we say, "Guide us the straight
path, the path of those whom your grace
is upon, not the path and way of those
who have earned your anger, nor the
misguided." Allah responds in real time
and says this is between my slave and
myself and for my slave what he asks of
me. He is not the golden calf of
Beni is in any way where he describes
that pathetic
golden calf that they worshiped aside
from Allah. He describes that pathetic
golden calf saying, "Do they not see
that that calf neither speaks to them
nor guides them?"
Allah
he speaks. Allah he responds. Allah he
guides.
Allah interacts with you with every
waking moment
and with every decision you make. Allah
is there with you at that junction every
time.
Every time
the prophet Sam
says in Muslim
and
[Silence]
that when a person stands before Allah
in prayer, Allah fixes is his face to
the face of his servant
and he will not turn away from his
servant until his his servant turns
away. And this is why in salah when we
end salah we turn away to signify the
end of that prayer, the end of that
connection.
Allah gives you that attention when you
stand in prayer before Allah. You have a
question, he's answered it already.
You have the greatest of answers that
was ever bestowed upon humanity, the
Quran.
And as it gathers dust on the shelves of
many Muslims,
and they wallow in agony wondering why
Allah will not respond to them. The
answer is sitting right there on the
shelf.
It's right there.
Pick it up.
Learn who Allah really is. Not who you
think he is. Not what this cynical
negative world teaches you Allah is.
Learn who Allah tells you he is.
The first description of Allah that you
or I
read when we open this great book of
light, the Quran is
Those are the descriptions of Allah.
No good deed goes unpunished. They say
this is not our belief in Allah. That's
not our Lord that we worship.
Those false gods that they worship, that
is their description. Our God that we
worship is the one who responds when we
call out. The one who answers when we
pray and ask. The one who guides when we
step.
The one who forgives when we seek his
forgiveness. And he interacts with us.
Every single time we stand in prayer,
every time we raise our hands to the
heavens, Allah responds.
And I Ahmed
Salman
who narrates that the prophet
said,
"Our prophet Sam
says indeed Your Lord
is very modest. He's shy of you and he
is very generous. He is too modest, too
shy from his own servant that when you
raise your two hands to him and ask him
that he will let you put those hands
back down to your sides empty.
He's too shy to let that happen. He is
too generous that every time you raise
your hands, they come back full of
Allah's generosity and mercy. If you
don't see them, that's the blindness
that you have incurred from this world.
That's not on him.
You have to learn to see.
If you cannot see your hands full of
Allah's mercy and generosity when they
come back down to your sides, it is
because you have been stricken, my
friend, with the blindness of the heart.
Because Allah tells us that true
blindness is not blindness of the eyes,
but true blindness is blindness of the
heart. If you can't see yourself
treading in Allah's mercy day and night,
then you are blind, my friend. If all
you can see is cynicism, if all you can
see is negativity, is if all you can see
is misery and oh my life should have
been and blind as in Allah and this and
that, you are blind, my friend. That is
not on him.
No one told you to listen to a shaitan.
Where did you get these descriptions of
Allah that you ascribed to him? Did you
get them from the Quran?
Who told you that this is who Allah is?
And so, my brothers and my sisters, we
don't worship a silent god. We don't
worship a god that is cynical and
sadistic. We worship Allah.
We worship the one that every time we
move our tongue to remember him, he
remembers us.
[Silence]
Allah says, "I am with my servant every
time he remembers me and moves his lips
with my name."
If he thinks of me, if he remembers me
in himself, I make mention of him in
myself.
And if he mentions me amongst a group of
people, I mention him amongst a superior
group.
Every time you mention Allah, he
mentions you. Every time you say his
name, he tells the angels around him
your name. That is the one we worship.
We don't worship the golden calf.
We don't worship the calf of Ben.
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Stand shoulder tosh shoulder. Align your
shoulders and feet. Take a moment to
look to your right and left. Make sure
that your shoulders and your feet are
directly in line with the shoulders and
feet of your two neighbors.
Straightening the road is a great part
of the reward of our prayer. If we fail
to straighten our rows, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala will not harmonize our hearts.
Ensure that you close the gaps. Do not
join a row unless the row in front of
you is completely filled to capacity.
Please turn your phones off so as to
honor this time with Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
canister.
I him.
[Silence]
will help you.
Allahel
me.
Allah.
Allahel.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
must.
[Silence]
for
And at the web
Allah
[Silence]
worthy They're known only woman
[Arabic recitation]
give you a couple of reminders. just
wanted to go over the programs that
masid offers and hopefully the people
who not may not know can benefit from
these inshallah. There is a hatra by
imam every fudger after every fudger and
after isha. So every day those hatras
are there and you please see if you can
find the time to to to benefit from
those. Also on Sunday program we have a
school program that is catering to the
kids of f between ages between 5 and 17
and that is from 10:30 a.m. to 1:30 p.m.
And again that is for the youth that can
benefit from the the activities at the
masjid and connect back to the masjid
inshallah. Also there's a Quran halaka
on Saturday and Sunday morning after
fudger. So that is very beneficial. If
anybody can find the time to join that
is really beautiful. It's again on fud
after fudger
and that is on Saturday and Sunday.
we also have Rahma Academy as you
know that is offering the pre from preK
all the way to the fifth grade. So
alhamdulillah school is in session.
Anybody that still has any students or
candidates that can come join benefit
from it. Please talk to brother Ahmed
Jabber and that will be definitely very
rewarding inshallah. one last thing I
wanted to talk to you about is the
parking. starting next week,
inshallah, we'll be enforcing the
parking rules and regulations that are
already in place. So nothing new. Park
in the designated parking only.
Designated parking spaces only. And
please do not block any ingress or
egress and please do not park in the
neighbors lots without any clear
understanding if that is allowed or not.
So if the if you find anything in
violation, you may find a yellow sticker
on your vehicle. So please avoid that
the best you can. Inshallah, donate
generously on the way out.
Hello.
[Silence]
I've seen him around.